right now crews are evaluating 300 dogs
found in dirty conditions in what
deputies call an unlicensed facility now
this is happening in armagosa valley and
nye county the 8 news now i-team's david
charns is there and david what are you
seeing out there
chris is not just what we are
also what we are hearing dogs wailing
and barking some we are told are as
young as a week old some kept in a
building like this one behind me as many
as 300 on this property
there are a lot of dogs in bad
conditions conditions described as dirty
and unsanitary 300 animals living on
this amargosa valley property in what
deputies call an unlicensed breeding
facility some puppies here as young as a
week old just kennels with a roof and
they're just lining the property they're
pretty unkept and most concerning is
that there's a lot of dogs and they're
obviously not friendly deputies say the
majority of the dogs are caucasian
shepherds a large breed sold for
security and protection investigators
came out here monday night for a report
of an injured animal sheriff's deputies
then arrested this pair they say he is
the owner she is the caretaker we have
to address and it's just kind of chaos
help from clark county came in to tag
and number each dog until deputies can
figure out their next steps it's always
sad no matter how many there are but
when there's hundreds and hundreds of
them obviously it's overwhelming
and these crews are expected to be out
here for several days working to help
these animals right now they're giving
them food and water they also say that
pair that you saw will be getting some
new charges as this investigation
continues we're live in amargosa valley
i'm david charns 8 news now